and joining us in the studio is the
founding president of the World Health
Summit detlef Canton welcome to the show
now climate change as we just saw could
have a serious impact on agriculture and
food availability what knock on effects
will that have for health care what
nutrition is so important for health and
children especially but also during all
ages and without proper nutrition
there's a no good health in the world so
it's of the utmost importance very
fundamental we've seen a steady
reduction in undernourishment in the
last few decades all over the world what
do experts say has to happen to keep
that positive trend going I mean even in
the face of climate change where we need
plants in eco culture which are more
resistant to heat than they are at the
present time and we know that from wheat
and other crops that you know the years
are decreasing so we'll have to do
something since climate is not so fast
we changed we need other crops wheat and
aunt mice and others who are better
adapted to this increased dealing with a
drier drier conditions less water and so
on well that climate change in health is
a big topic at this year's World Health
Summit apart from food availabilities
availability what are some of the other
aspects of climate change that could
impact on health care what has changes
in weather it's kind of thunderstorms
it's floodings it's vectors of
infectious diseases which spread in
other regions like malaria for example
so more the other diseases more diseases
are spreading over the globe so it's a
plethora of various aspects which need
to be considered what about migration I
mean all of those all of those aspects
are going to mean that migration among
people happens more quiet we see that
now and well across Europe you know one
is the political system but the other
one is nutrition of course and living
conditions and climate is a major factor
in this aspect also